gddr5 memory goes back pretty far with
production getting back all the way to
2008 gddr5 ex is much more recent with
the production standard being
standardized in just January of 2016 in
2017 GT tr6 memory was standardized and
then later in 2018 the production began
and then at the end of 2018 we saw
implemented invidious high-end Turner's
in 2019 there are several GPUs and maybe
even consoles that are going to be
coming out which will make the center
much more popular so what even is gr6
memory and what will it bring to the
table
[Music]
welcome to Haris hobbies first of all
what even is gtv6 memory well gee dr6
memory is a type of VRAM their graphics
card uses to store things such as
lighting information and textures for
your games
it holds the data their GP and each sub
processes in order to display ER game on
to monitor
typically the higher the resolution the
more stressed herbs on the vram and 4k
monitors be more common nowadays and
high-end technology being implemented to
cheap use like rakers technology it is
essential that there are improvements in
the VM and the latest iteration is GD r6
g DD r6 is an abbreviation for graphics
double data rate type 6 synchronous
dynamic random access memory it brings a
handful of significant upgrades to gddr5
and GD r 5x memory or one of the most
major differences in transfer speeds
gddr5 has transfer speeds of 8 gigabits
per second GD r 5x memory has transfer
rates of about 10 to 12 gigabits per
second GD r 6 on the other hand has
transfer speeds of 14 to 16 K bits per
second that's about twice as fast as
gddr5 memory and about 25% faster than
GD r 5x memory which isn't bad at all
one of the biggest upgrades on to GD r 6
memory is efficient
see it consumes a lot less power than
GTA 5 and GTA 5 X Emery and it also has
a lower power draw at one point three
volts as opposed to 1.5 volts for gddr5
X Emery
next up GTR six is a first theorem where
the DRM vendor can choose to run full
speeds up qtr or DDR ddr2 data rate is
what we've been accustomed to in the
past decade DDR can send and receive two
signals per clock cycle
personname double data rate QD r or quad
data rate will allow for four signals to
be sent and received every clock cycle
furthermore qgr six will have to truly
independent 16-bit channels gddr5 only
had one 32-bit channel to get 5x still
only had a one 32-bit channel but it
could be split to 16 bits tudo channels
overall do deserve 6 memory is not run
for Lucia nary by any means as the usual
upgrades and bandwidth capacity and
efficiency the dual tone feature however
is unexpected and it's been a nice for
workloads
which lot of parallel reads and writes
to different parts of the memory the
updates to QDR and DDR are also a nice
bonus in the end
GT tier 6 memory is not going to make
that big of a difference in terms of
gaming performance and you're not going
to be really missing out with gddr5 or
gddr5 X memory by Gd r6 memory is
definitely a step in the right direction
and will make your life just that much
better so is there anything crucial that
I missed about GTD r6 memory and what
computer or hardware concept would you
like me to cover next make sure comment
down down below also if you found this
video helpful they make you drop the
like and consider subscribing if you
would like to see more videos just like
this one but until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]